I remember the first time I saw you
riding I mean really riding you're maybe
10 years old I got jealous such a
natural gift we play this right we have
a real shot at Rookie of the Year I want
you to call me when you get to the hotel
Wow what's that learn to love that chair
that is your freedom mom will you
promise me that alright again if I have
to strap you in that sat on myself now
as you start to do more stuff for
yourself you're gonna find that things
that once came naturally are not
difficult and that's okay maybe you
could do something know that rodeo rodeo
isn't something I do it's really it's
Who I am
I can't write like I used to I never
want to write again don't you give up
this chair will either be your wings or
it will be your anchor you decide
get over here ready be my leg
[Music]
look at that
[Music]
no matter what Matt gives you get more
back
is there a future in rodeo am I really
worried I can't quit you can put me down
now no I can we don't always get to
choose what happens to us but we do get
to choose what we do next
you
[Music]
you